ist irgendwie voll das versteckte
placement jetzt aber sollte ich krieg
dafür kein geld zu 100 prozent nur da
fragt man sich natürlich weiß jetzt
instagram dass ich eine kreditkarte
besitzen oder warum wird man das
angezeigt so versteht ihr wenn ihr jetzt
schon ziemlich lange facebook habt weiß
facebook mail bei euch als eure besten
freundin etwas gedacht man jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's
gut heute mal wirklich früh am morgen
okay wir haben gerade 11 uhr früh ist
das nicht mehr
aber normalerweise nehme ich meine
videos er so abends auf oder halt
nachmittags aber ich habe gerade lust
dieses video aufzunehmen
deswegen macht man das jetzt und zwar
ich weiß nicht ob mein letztes video
gesehen hat und auch mein vorletztes da
ging es darum jede youtube werbung die
ich sehe muss ich kaufen oder zumindest
mal anschauen von cristiano ronaldo ach
ist ja ein schnäppchen 100 149 euro für
einen koffer es ist aber okay ich nehme
mir natürlich in pinker habe ich jetzt
nicht alles von gekauft weil ich nicht
1000 euro für eine sprachreise ausgeben
wollte aber jetzt machen wir das ganze
noch mal und ich hoffe diesmal haben wir
echt geile produkte die man mal eben
schnell bekommen kann und kaufen kann
sei es jetzt im supermarkt sei es im
restaurant sei es keine ahnung wo damit
ich das heißt gleichzeitig in dieses
video packen kann und zwar geht es heute
um die app instagram ich weiß nicht ob
die kennt da kann man so fotos posten
und da ist natürlich auch immer alles
voll mit werbung zumindest bei mir ich
weiß nicht ob das bei euch auch so ist
aber es wird irgendwie immer mehr
werbung genau für die das konzept noch
nicht ganz verstanden haben es geht
einfach darum dass ich heil runter
scrollen und immer wenn der werbung mehr
angezeigt wird muss ich die auch direkt
kaufen und alles was mir angezeigt wird
was ich jetzt nicht direkt kaufen kann
werde ich halt dann im nächsten video
wenn es halt da ist alles zusammen
präsentieren irgendwann nächste woche
oder so kein plan wenn ihr das format so
cool findet und ich darf noch mehr teile
machen soll dann lasst auf jeden fall
jetzt schon mal nen fetten daumen nach
oben da ich würde sagen wir laufen gar
nicht lange fangen direkt mal an und ich
muss hier erstmal ein bildschirm
aufnehmen das gute ist das geht ja beim
iphone jetzt auch bildschirmaufnahme 321
sowie sind hier direkt vom instagram
profil alex wie 227.000 voller war
mal schauen ob ich nach diesem video
228.000 habe deswegen geht auf jeden
fall gern worüber eigentlich gehe jetzt
hier einfach so ein bisschen über mein
feed und besucht die erste werbung und
ich bin mal gespannt was das sein wird
leider muss ich mir jetzt erstmal sehr
viele von diesen leuten anschauen wenig
folge aber das macht gar keinen spaß ist
okay ich habe die erste werbung gefunden
und zwar
[Musik]
genieße jede sekunde des spiels verpasst
sich die fifa wir machen zahlung schnell
einfach damit du stehst du bleibst
das ding ist hier ging es gerade um eine
visa card kreditkarte und das trifft
sich eigentlich ganz gut denn die habe
ich schon jetzt nicht im blau aber hier
natürlich die goldene so wie sich das
gehört hier spaß ich weiß gar nicht auf
die goldene besser ist als nur glaube
ich glaube ja nicht nur da fragt man
sich natürlich weiß jetzt instagram dass
ich eine kreditkarte besitzen oder warum
wird das angezeigt so versteht ihr weil
es liegt natürlich sehr nah auch vor
allem wenn man das facebook profil auch
noch mit dem instagram profil verknüpft
hat es heißt ja so schön wenn jetzt
schon ziemlich lange facebook habt weiß
facebook mail bei euch als eure besten
freunde ich würde sagen wir schauen
einfach mal schnell weiter was wir hier
noch so finden guck mal hier bin ich fan
page alex wie allemal abonnieren das
bild habe ich schon gesagt okay leute
ich hab die nächste werbung gefunden
moment hier sofort los ich muss noch
einmal von vorn abspielen mcdonald's
werbung mit einem dino der durch den
macd whiteboard und nummer 158 weil wir
verstehen können wenn wir heute vor dem
kinobesuch uns essen kommst oder so hier
muss ich jetzt ehrlich sagen die werbung
finde ich scheiße also deswegen würde
ich niemals zu mcdonald's gehen
natürlich bewegt ist im unterbewusstsein
wie der song hey bei uns gibt es
leckeres essen auch wenn ich halt
wirklich nicht auf da bin aber ich habe
es ja am anfang gesagt was bleibt uns
anderes übrig also leute auf göttliche
werden sagt mittag
hey ohne spaß was ist das für ein wetter
ich habe ich mal das wetter an das ist
so heftig am regen die straßen hier wo
ich bin zwar kein dino und ich will auch
nicht ins kino
das freut sich sogar aber ich hätte
gerne den happy meals
cheeseburger cola ketchup noch gar
nichts davon
daniel frucht klatsch ich habe mir jetzt
zum mittag erst mal schnell was essen
geholt ich erst mal eben entspannt auf
und dann melde ich mich vielleicht dann
gehst du nicht weiter so leute wissen
einfach mal weiter und weiter und weiter
und weiter und weiter und weiter und
weiter und weiter und weiter und weiter
hier ist das kann ich auch meinen vielen
hunde brauchen eine familie eine
wirklich coole seite also wenn ihr den
hund sucht schaut auf jeden fall mal
dort vorbei da werden täglich hunde aus
tierheimen gepostet die halten zuhause
suchen kann man wirklich nur
unterstützen finde ich richtig gut
ich sage ja immer bescheid werde ich die
nächste werben gefunden habe so leute
hier haben was auch schon und zwar club
geht ich bin mir jetzt gerade unsicher
ob ich die sache fire oder überhaupt
nicht wobei ich sagen muss diese jacke
finde ich eigentlich ganz nice ich
schaue einfach mal wie teuer die ist 56
euro für diese jacke wohl die finde ich
eigentlich geiler als die die will ich
haben
heute schreibt mal genau jetzt in die
kommentare
findet ihr diese jacke geil ja oder nein
ich habe ja gesagt ich kaufe das
deswegen bestellen wir die einfach mal
in grau
ich finde diese skoda logo darauf
eigentlich ganz cool
das ganze wird natürlich jetzt nicht
ankommen die aufnahme wurde der unterbau
mit 4 64 euro
ich glaube das ist mit versandkosten
also ich würde sagen wir bestellen
einfach mal diese jacke und ich bin
gespannt wenn sie an kommt also diese
klappe seite hat auf jeden fall glück
wenn es mehr so leute wie mich gibt die
einfach alles kaufen was ihn angezeigt
wird
dann machen die wahrscheinlichen
wahnsinns geschäft gut ich würde sagen
wir scrollen einfach mal weiter
lalalalala heute morgen war es
wirklichkeit ne 19 grad und jetzt sitze
ich hier und fangen an zu schwitzen so
leute ich habe die nächste werbung
gefunden und zwar als trendy habe ich
vorher ehrlich gesagt noch nie gesehen
und was das genau sein soll weiß ich
auch nicht
wir gehen einfach mal auf jetzt
einkaufen also kann man anscheinend
masken kaufen das ding ist das kommt
wahrscheinlich aus den usa und bis das
hier ist ich werde jetzt hier einfach
mal den joker ziehen bevor ich 27 euro
und sand setzte die gebe ich lieber für
was anderes aus deswegen tut es mir an
dieser stelle leid ich schau mal schnell
weiter diese werbung habe ich jetzt
nicht gekauft aber zwei finden wir
bestimmt noch hier und mal eben schnell
bekommen kann so laut ich habe die
nichts werbung gefunden und zwar ist es
ein netflix werbung ich schau mal kurz
rein jetzt ja kein ton
[Musik]
ok ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe
letztens ich finde es eigentlich so
krass weil ich kann mir wirklich nicht
vorstellen dass das jetzt nur zufälle
sind hier steht einen monat gratis
ausprobieren filme und serien jederzeit
und überall genießen auf die eigenen
vorlieben abgestimmt 100 kostenlos
ausprobieren und ich habe letztens
irgendwann mal gedacht netflix immer
wieder ganz cool ich habe noch einmal
sein prime ich wollte mich dann auch
wirklich dafür anmelden habe dann aber
irgendwie doch nicht gemacht und jetzt
wird mir hier angezeigt dass ich mich
100 gratis dafür registrieren kann und
ist halt jetzt die perfekte gelegenheit
dazu deswegen beginnen wir einfach mal
hier den gratis monat ist irgendwie voll
das versteckte place will jetzt aber
leute ich krieg dafür kein geld zu 100
prozent
sie können sich ja wir brauchen hier das
basis also für 799 braucht halt nur mich
weiter ok fertig mal schauen was es
soviel schöne serien gibt so weit ich
habe mir jetzt hier netflix gemacht wir
haben das jetzt erst mal für einen monat
gratis und wenn ich dann keinen bock
mehr habe muss ich nicht mal geld
bezahlen kann es einfach wieder
abbestellen
das heißt irgendwie könnte man sich ja
dann nein das geht wahrscheinlich auch
nicht man kann sich nicht jeden monat in
kraft das monat machen aber ist auf
jeden fall echt cool ich finde netflix
eigentlich auch cooler als amazon prime
einfach weil es da bessere serien gibt
vor allem ihr diese serie house des
geldes war die kann ich euch eigentlich
nur empfehlen also wenn ihr netflix
haben solltet oder ich es machen wollt
dass annette faße wäre wie oder das ist
irgendwie sonst kann ich aber aus das
geld es ist wirklich gut und wir machen
jetzt weiter hey leute ich glaube das
ding ist wenn man so weit runter
gescrollt hat dass man irgendwie schon
so 67 werbung gesehen hat kommt einfach
keine mehr
ich finde keine werbung mehr deswegen
schließen wir jetzt einfach mal kurz die
app und warten ein bisschen und dann
schaue ich mal ob ich noch eine werbung
findet so weit ich will sagen zum
abschluss eine werden können wir noch
mit dem okay ich habe etwas gefunden
louis vuitton tasche okay ich bin jetzt
auch eine handtasche für moment 1490
euro
alles klar leute damit beenden wir das
video erwarte man dass ich mir jetzt
echt mal also hier muss ich jetzt
wirklich rätseln warum wir so eine
tasche angezeigt wird
ist ja auch vor allem die damen tasche
wahrscheinlich denkt louie vito ach der
ist youtuber der kauf bestimmt gerne mal
eben so eine tasche nein und ich glaube
ich habe jetzt fünf sachen gekauft eine
sache habe ich nicht kauft ok 2 aber ich
denke das sollte dir verstehen sollte
das war's mit dem video ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen wenn ihr bock hat auch
noch ein paar mit zb fernsehwerbung das
stelle ich mir eigentlich am lustigsten
vor dann hast du auf jeden fall jetzt
mann vettel noch nach oben
münster bewahrt und wir sehen uns
sonntag wieder gibt es ein neues video
hat rein